we're adding an eighth show in Austin on
June 10th uh tickets go on sale
Wednesday at 10 A.M local time you'll be
able to get those so don't go and pay
those overpriced resellers uh sale
amounts and that goes the same for Miami
um for other cities we're going to be
coming to I'll add a show or I'll come
back through
but uh let's don't give those guys all
that cash
those guys are Crooks I'd rather
um I'd rather come back
uh we'll also we will be adding at some
point
um Europe and Australia I just don't
know when yet so thank you for your
patience there it just we don't know so
we're looking at it it's a lot
and we don't want to go and just have to
hurry it up we want to enjoy ourselves
when we come New York City Las Vegas
Uncasville Connecticut and Toronto all
still have tickets always get your
tickets at theovan.com t-o-u-r
[Music]
um thank you very much for your support
to any show you've come to uh we love
you
what's up guys
um
my name's Theo and I'm a human
I am
what's going on I've been uh
been running around a lot been you know
on the go
you know I mean just
I feel like the Lord just put that go
Celine in me
you know that
91 octane or whatever
and I've been burning boy I've been go
go going
um
and sometimes it's hard to get a moment
to
was hard to get a moment these days
you know I think about that a lot and
it's hard for me to like get a moment
where it's like okay this is a moment
that's not where I'm not being pulled or
pushed or interrupted or overwhelmed or
well overwhelmed's okay
but where I'm not being like
where I'm not needing or wanting
anything except for
some of my own
time
like I just want to
have I have enough peace or whatever
going on so I can evaluate where I am
sometimes these things are so busy so
hectic you don't even know what's going
on
you haven't even looked at you know
sometimes you're so busy you don't even
look at you know you'll take your pulse
in the evening and you're you were you
died in the morning you didn't even know
it
because you just been
you just kept you know you were just
running on fume but you kept going
you're like damn well you died
and you run into a butt he's like oh
damn you're you're dude you gotta
lay down you're dead you know you died
earlier
but that's what it's like these days
things get so busy that um
you know I don't know if I'm living
sometimes or if I'm doing a to-do list
and then I don't know whose to-do list
it is sometimes
I don't know if it's my own things that
I want to be doing
is it things that I feel like
people want me to be doing
like whose expectations am I
living up to
or am I chasing
or am I trying to fulfill
that's what I wonder sometimes
um
and I can just ask myself well hey who's
is this your dream you're doing is this
your
goal you're doing is this and that can
be anything anything you're doing
throughout your day or you know if in
your plans or in your week or something
that you're a current
you know job or
um
undertaking a relationship even it could
be anything that you're doing
or committing yourself to
and I I'll just ask myself sometimes
who's
who's goal is this whose expectation is
this mine
is this um
my parents is this a God is this who
what am I doing
and for whom am I doing it
um
and so I think yeah some of getting some
moments of time where I have to myself
you know I just I need that to touch
base with myself and
just to look at the charts
you know it's like somebody you don't
look at your chart you don't look at
your own
you don't take enough inventory of
yourself and
you know yeah you don't even know what's
going on you finally look at your chart
and you're like yeah damn huh
you know I took a wrong turn four months
ago but I just didn't even you know I
didn't stop and look at where I've been
because I just
think that if I keep going
I'll get some I'll get I don't know
I don't know I'm kind of rambling
but sometimes these days you get so busy
you don't you know
by the time you look at your uh
your chart you were supposed to use date
you just died a week ago
and you're just out here damn ghost and
doing stuff
making Wagers online and
uh
you know going buying stuff at uh
Trader Joe's
and [__] and you're down you're supposed
to be deceased and you're like oh damn I
didn't even
I was so busy lit you know living or
doing that I didn't even
realize I was damn gone
that's how busy you can get these days
it feels like
um
anyway sorry if that was kind of a down
or I didn't mean to be a Debbie Downer
or whatever but I just yeah I think I've
just been running so much it's
um I'm trying to get a little bit of
take some inventory of myself let's see
what the what's what's going on with you
how are you what's up
um
So and I've been a lot I think I've been
a little bit burnt out you know I got to
get a week off sometime soon I'm gonna
take a um
vacation
in a vacation that's just where
I mean that's kind of where you tell
that's where you tell time to kind of
hold you nuts bruh
so yeah let me do that let me um
let me
think about what I've been
let me take a moment I feel uh
you know I've been worried recently
about my own ego
I've been worried a lot about my own ego
um
just because the ego it's such a sneaky
thing it's like your Shadow but
but it's on the inside of you
and its goal is to
is to is to trick you to think that
you're having self-confidence
that's what I think let me see what is
it ego
a person's sense of self-esteem or
self-importance
um
the part of the mind that mediates
between the conscious and the
unconscious
and is responsible for a sense of
personal identity
yeah I think I just I think I've just
been worried about my ego a little
um
you know I think there's there's things
have just kind of gotten busier and
stuff and so I just
I just worry about it
you know I want to be I want to try and
be
you know I can just feel it flare up
here and there like
um
oh why isn't this this way or what you
know expecting things to be perfect
expecting
and it's not like I deserve them to be
perfect but it's still it's an
expectation that things should be or
things why aren't things going smoothly
what you know so I just
I just want to have awareness of that
because that's a work man if you have if
your ego is leading the drive this and
then you're it's not even you
that's not even
it's you but it's you just you're
working for this
you working for a damn dirty landlord
brother if your ego is running the show
so
anyway that's been something that's been
going on what else
um
yeah I want to take a vacation so I'm
going to do that sometime and uh
yeah just still battling trying to stay
off the Vapes it's been a war
I had five days at one point and then I
seceded
I succeeded uh
to the union or whatever I don't know
what I seceded to but I gave up
and I just damn Hit that [__] son
and I've been on I've been on I've been
I've been on them bro
God I've been on them
dude you I mean
if you wrote damn Vapes in here dude
inside of it right out if you wrote If
you wrote If you wrote Vapes in here on
the outside of a wishing well
and you came there at night with a
flashlight and looked down in there
I'd be in there
and I'd be damned just wishing for Vapes
and so anyway that's what's been going
on dude I just wanted to touch just
check in
um
of things that have just kind of been on
my mind and heart a little bit and uh
yeah we'll get into some episode man
it's been an exciting few weeks I'm
sorry that I haven't gotten to be here
with you guys for one-on-one hanging out
um
let's get into it and then we'll uh
and then we'll be into it
praise God baby
gang
a long time ago
[Music]
[Applause]
you will see the cigarette bottles on
the wall
[Music]
and all the empty bottles in the hall
if the water gets to rough you know who
to call cause you babies
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
that's him right there that's 89 volt
and he is baby
God baby he's a damn uh he's that
mulatto Canary right there baby
Eddie nine volt he's got all the colors
in his throat
oh man you down
you beat you I mean you could just damn
beat a 64 pack of crayons
right out of his tonsils I bet he's just
he
God he's got it in him 89 volt little
black flies
and that's what that's called right
there
and if you have a beautiful tune or
something if you're a band that does
beautiful music and it's something new
and novel you could send it in
uh to the email to the producer and
we'd like to sometimes put some new
music out there
what's been up uh what's been up with
you
what's been up with you
you know if there's something going on
with yourself
um
if there's something you feel like
you've been keeping or haven't sharing
or something like that or
um something that's been burdening you
um you know you can always hit the
hotline it's 985-664-9503
and put it in there
put it in there you know you know
and uh some of them we get to some of
them we don't we listen all of them may
take a while but uh
sometimes it's nice to just get
something out of you
to get something out of your uh chest
um I'm upstairs
I wanted to put that on you for
everybody that came out uh the past few
weeks and sat out in the balconies up
there
and the John Wilkes booths you know just
if anybody if you're up in there in that
balcony that's
a lot of things happened up there
people back there doing dice you know
somebody back there selling um
organic ketamine somebody
you know they'll have somebody there
that's on ketamine
and then they'll be just
you know pulling dandruff off up and
selling just organic damn ketamine right
off a dude
they're just you know bagging up uh
dandruff off a uh some dude that's in a
k hole and slanging that [__] bam
next thing you know somebody else is in
the bathroom
they're damn they're in there you know
and they're doing kind of they're doing
you know uh dandruff fan Academy you
know ketamine that's cut with dandruff
like well dang this guy
you know next thing you know the guys
out there just
just ejaculating outside of a damn uh
sports clips
or whatever
wherever you wherever you get your hair
cut
dude I remember one time when I was um
God I don't know I was
probably
well I was real we were poor so I don't
I don't know if it really matters what
age you are when you're that poor when
you're poor as we were I don't think it
nobody don't matter
you could be two you could be eleven
fourteen all the
the same shit's happening around you
people are smoking
somebody's touching somebody illegally
um
the water is going to be shut off it's
the same type of [__] so
age is really
you know knowing every year is kind of
something I think that wealthier people
do
you know
oh Weston is seven you know
meanwhile a little [__] uh Ricky bruh
Little Ricky who's you know ambidextrous
in his own neck
because he get you know because somebody
in his family shouldn't have been making
love bruh Little Ricky he he he he uh
he he might be three he might be 15
though he's over there just smoking door
rails and chilling baby
and it don't matter you don't know where
he's coming in he wets the bed that's
how he
you know he'll leave me he'll wet the
bed and leave a message in this pit in
the urine on the sheets I need help
it'll say on it I mean these
that's where I'm from
where the the desk the the desire that
fur just damn
for just for you know you'll piss what
you need right into the damn bed milk I
used to piss that into the sheet
you know launch I'd write just piss
you'd wake up and I'd roll over and pull
back the top sheet and I just said just
cleanly pissed
just damn just wiener calligraphy come
right out of me lunch right on the sheet
damn
so if you're a therapist you could pull
off that tie every week you could have
seen what I needed
lunch oh
uh field trip signature on document that
took me I take me three nights to
urinate that into the thing
but Mom would be gone I wouldn't have
nobody would be there to sign it for me
so I just falsify it
hug from Dad piss that into the [__] you
know
but that's where I'm from where you
were we talking about Jesus I don't know
um
something about children
sorry yeah I'm all over the place I'm
all over the place that's where I am
right now that's how I feel
and I want to be able to come to this
show with how I feel every week I feel
all over the place
and
and I'm not complaining but I want you
know I want to be able to it's sometimes
interesting because if you have some
success and people see you doing well
then they you can't share how you're
feeling
you know it's interesting
um
but oh well that's not my problem
you know uh I just want to be able to
share how I'm feeling no matter what
and uh
yeah
but I'm not trying to get into self-pity
I'm not feeling sorry for myself
um damn what was I talking about
when I was growing up
oh so my mother one time took me to get
a uh haircut
and
she took me to get a haircut and this
lady named Miss I think her name was
Miss Bobby
Miss Billy Miss Bobby she had a male
name
you know and I think her they'd wanted
her to be a man
I mean they had I remember she pictures
of her she was when I met her she was
probably 90. or 89 she might have been
89.
but she um and she was a barber
you know or she at least she owned the
barber clothing in an art and where I'm
from that was if you own if you had the
outfit bro that was it
you didn't need a diploma
you know what I'm saying if you where
I'm from if you had a if you had
overalls you had a you farmed
you know you might live you might live
in an apartment but you got uh you know
three corn bushes out front and you
doing corn once a year
you know um
you could have like if my if you owned a
name tag you just and it said your name
on it you walk in any damn Shoney's and
just start working
it didn't matter that you wasn't on
staff it didn't matter
you wrote you walk in that [__] you
write on there Ricky's daddy or whatever
on the time car you clock in as long as
you had a name tag then you were bam
qualified baby
that's where I'm from
and uh
yeah I'm from threes McGee Street baby
Covington Louisiana
where we burn [__] in the ditches baby
that's what we did over there
you want to know who I am that's who I
am
where we go out there and do all
we do you know we we get a little water
on us or something and
we'd Run and Jump back and forth through
the smoke if people were burning trash
we jumped through the smoke back and
forth
just you know kind of just this Smoky
little Double Dutch where you just
jumping from side to side until your
whole body you were black
we just beat I mean we'd be damned we
had black face black body black neck
I mean black I'd even
if you were naked that wiener get a
little black now that far it kind of
that was you know you had to hey you
enjoyed that
now we be down I mean I mean the cops
which that's how but we got dark we
jumped through that smoke all the damn
cops would show up
and uh
but that's where I'm from baby that's
where I'm from
um
and maybe I'll have to take my address
out there so people don't go over there
to those people's home but uh
this episode is brought to you by
betterhelp that's right
if you've struggled with getting
um mental Wellness for yourself
if you struggled in having purpose if
you struggled in knowing
what's going on you feel like you have
more questions than answers
um and you don't feel good
some of that can be natural but some of
it can be more than you can handle and
when that's the case better help is
there for you that's right
therapy is all about deepening your
self-awareness and understanding
because sometimes we don't know what we
want or why we react the way we do
better help
connect you with a licensed therapist
who can take you on that journey of
self-discovery from wherever you are
if you're thinking of starting therapy
give better help a try I've tried Better
Health and I found it to be useful
visit betterhelp.com
t-h-e-o today to get 10 off your first
month that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com slash Theo and I
want to let you know if you're ever
injured you can check out Morgan and
Morgan
and Morgan is America's largest injury
Law Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients Morgan Morgan has a proven
track record
submitting an injury claim with Morgan
and Morgan is so easy
that's right uh it's more like using an
app than hiring a lawyer
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless you they win for more information
go to forthepeople.com slash this past
weekend or dial pound law which is pound
529 from your cell phone that's for the
people.com
this past weekend or pound law pound 529
from your cell this is a paid
advertisement anyway what's going on
with you guys I'm sorry for talking
about myself so much you can hit the
hotline 985-664-9503
and let us know what's going on with you
um
and that's always open
yeah but miss uh Bobby I think her name
was Miss Bobby so she was a haircutter
or she had the uniform
so at one point
uh
the bus driver you originally cut our
hair
and he drove bus one uh Mr Ray was his
name and he pulled the bus over
uh once every couple weeks and he cut
everybody on that [__] everybody got
the same cut on that [__] everybody
so
but something happened to him
something happened to him I think he I
don't remember I think he might have
been changing a tire and got hit by a
vehicle or something you know
natural causes or whatever you know
whatever natural causes were back then
um
something happened to Mr Ray and so we
had to go to miss Bobby or Miss bill I
can't remember her name Bobby or Billy
and they wanted her to be a man you
could tell you sold pictures of her they
had always her Daddy had dressed her up
like a man when she was a kid and they
wrote even you know you'd see somebody
write man man in here on her back
you know somebody would write that on
her back and you know she'd have a
picture of her in college and somebody
written man in in here on her back I
think that might have been the original
trans with somebody just writing you
know
man in here
on her back
uh and we got it everybody got the point
you didn't have to get the sex you
didn't have to do all of that
so really saves a lot of money which I
think
that's nice you write man in here on
each arm he showed that to me when I
roll up I get it
all right Bridget I'll call you Bradley
I get it boom that's it we don't need
you know we we don't need a lot of other
Insanity around it
if you trans and out we've all everybody
damn
sometimes I feel like a love [__] you
feel me
sometimes I feel like three tenths of a
[__]
you know and I kind of see what I you
know
I'll let it pass or something I remember
I don't know I guess I don't have a lot
of him I never put on panties or nothing
but anyway so let me get through the
story so she was the hair cutter and I
was over there one time
and my mom would drop me off because
that old lady she was real chatty she'd
talk to me she damn
she talked to you by the time she got
done talking to you you know it was
she was 91 if she'd 90 she's not he was
just like dang man
so she kept talking and so Mom would
drop me off there mama would drop me off
there and uh
and I got the cut I get that trim but
one time I was in there she had a stroke
right
and she's laying on the ground with the
scissors you know and I'd never been
around somebody that had a stroke I
didn't know what it was
and so I just sat there man
you know I feel bad about it I was well
behaved but I sat there for probably
15 minutes
and I thought she was just being real
quiet or something or I don't know what
I thought
maybe she was doing hide and go seek but
she just
forgot to hide and thought she was
hiding or something I don't know what I
thought at that age but I remember just
being in that room and it was quiet as
could be
foreign
came or something
and he's like what the hell happened in
here and he called me a
and uh
anyway
what else man sorry I'm just going off
on it that's where I'm at I'm all over
the place
um I just got back from uh
I just got back from
Medford Massachusetts
over there at the casino ballroom
and that was an interesting venue for
comedy I I uh I appreciate everybody
that came out the setup of it isn't
ideal for comedy uh but a nice staff
over there beautiful
um and a lot of beautiful people that
came out and
God it was freezing and was it was
bizarre and freezing over there and um
and yeah next time we'll try to find a
video that's a little more suited for
comedy it's a I think for rock and roll
or for
um you know if you're going to see like
a little peep uh
reenactment or you know if Disney does
like little peep on ice or whatever
then I think it's great but I think for
comedy for me it was tough because I
like everybody to be able to see me in
the front
and this was I came around the sides a
little bit so
um but I was thinking about that I was
like how do I the second night I was
like how do I adjust the show so
everybody can see perfectly and uh
anyway we did our best and I just want
to thank everybody who came out there
who came out in Houston
who came out previously before that in
Boston
um down there in Corpus Christi
um yeah it's just been a lot of places I
didn't get to do as many uh pop outs
into the lobby to thank people we tried
some this weekend the lobbies were small
um in Houston we did one night or two
nights we came out and it was just uh
pretty chaotic
so
um we'll just trying our best you know
I'll try my best to pop out there
afterwards for people that are male uh
kind of hanging around and um
but I just want to let you know that
because some people would send me a DMV
like you know I didn't and be like we
came out you just you know we we don't
you had already been gone by the time we
got out there sometimes we didn't get to
do it
um but we try and I just want to let you
know that I think about that
um what else
oh uh Billy conforto's brother
came out and his name is Chuck Chuck
mints
named after the candy I think but they
spell it different
they spell it different uh
and everybody a lot of you guys know
Billy conforto and you remember them
and
man he was
you know Billy was the first
he was a homosexual
um
kind of uh prize fighter slash
busboy
that was a lot of you know I would say
those were his domains really and he
would
you know he damn you know
he'd hand job a male waiter and he'd
have but at the same with the other hand
he'd be you know cleaning up a four top
so he'd be polishing off a a
one type and a four he'd be
you know he could do a bottom and a four
top at the same time that's who he was
and
and when I met him he we were working at
like a fine dining type of place but
nobody ever came in there
so we were just
doing whippets mostly
and we did so many whippets one time he
just told me that he was gay and I think
that that and that was the first gay
human I'd ever met
and uh anyway he and I became good
friends over the years and and he would
sell uh he sold he sold a lot of good
weed
I think it was good now I'll say this
he had Billy uh also had
a lot of attack animals
he had attack animals
and if you don't know what that is go up
to an animal
and
and if you get attacked
then now you know
so he had all he had a lot of pit bulls
and he would train him I mean these
things were
he'd be like oh it's the nicest dog deal
bro it's the nicest dog and then you go
pet it and it would it would [__]
rearrange your fingers on your hand
so he would get you you get you you get
high with him and then the dog would be
so scary that I would be I'd be on the
furniture
I'd be hanging from the sillim fan
so I think a lot of people
they would see that they're like damn
that's the best weed in the world this
dude's hanging you know
this dude's doing interior design in the
house he's you know
he's living in one of the dresser
drawers this guy is [__] up
that must be the gas weed right
so anyway but the truth was he had a
dangerous animals and if you bring an
attack animal with you and you get
somebody High even on skunk weed
then suddenly your [__] is the greatest
[__] they have
because if somebody sees you know
somebody take a couple puffs of your
stuff and then they run across the field
yelling help me
they're going to be like damn that's
killer weed
but really that's just killer and he's a
you know four-year-old uh American Pit
Bull Rescue
so
his brother came out man and that was
beautiful to get to spend time with him
that was in Baton Rouge I don't think I
mentioned that
and he brought his uh
Billy conforto's niece and uh nephew
and it was good to see that their births
weren't affected by drugs or anything
you know there were two able-bodied
children and
uh
mentally able
and very kind
and um it was just great man it was
great it was like I was there with Billy
for a minute you know it was uh
it was pretty special
and what else we reached out over there
to do a special plaque or something for
him in uh in Louisiana and so far the
places that we've reached out there over
there in Mandeville we've have gotten
denied so far so we're still seeing what
we can do we want to do something a
little bit
like nicer something uh
you know you can't just do it if you
call any place they say oh you can do it
or you you know everybody can't call and
put up a uh
you know a peach tree for you know
somebody for Boo Radley or whoever died
because it'll be all trees so you have
to do something different so I don't
know we'll figure it out but I just
wanted everybody to know and on the
YouTubes we got pictures of his family
that came out
um what else I'm gonna have a simple
water right now
I'm gonna take a moment for myself and
have a sip of water
praise God baby
come upstairs
ah
what else man I went on a little coffee
date
yesterday I met up with a gal
and uh
uh we had a little coffee and she showed
up I think she was on some type of uh
she seemed like she was on a
um
stimulants
I'll say that
I think she was on damn stimulants bro
because I was uh
she was like trying to listen fast you
ever talk to somebody and they just keep
getting closer to you bro like they just
like they just
like they're not gonna hear your next
word they're gonna try and [__] it you
know
like they just like boy you put that
word out here I'm gonna [__] that thing
like that she would just seem like real
stimulated
so I think she was on some damn stimulus
man so
I just ordered a salad and chatted with
her for maybe
27 minutes
then we took a little walk around on the
sun went in the Sun
because I like staying in the sun when I
walk
and uh and then that was it
went our separate ways
um
oh man I long for the days when I could
whenever everything felt uh
normal when everything felt a little bit
more categorized inside of me
and specifically in my brain and so
that's where I started noticing for
myself I got to slow things down a
little bit and give things a little bit
of an opportunity
um but I got Zach here Zach's gonna help
me with the news today
uh producer Zach how are we
I'm good I need one second but I'm good
okay hold on give me a second no take a
moment for yourself man
that's what we're talking about today
but cut that audio off if you don't mind
so we can have our moment too while
you're having your moment
you know silence that's that's going to
become part of a premium I noticed that
you go a place now and there's 17
screens going and there's a damn
violin and there's uh
somebody playing a
somebody playing a machine gun I mean
there's all kind of stuff
um
you know it's hard to get a little piece
these days
and that's one thing that was nice up
there in New Hampshire one thing that
was nice was um
the Wentworth Hotel
and man if you could bring that bring
that up Zacky
this place is and I think a lot of
people go there for the uh summer time
but let me tell you you want a good
night you want us some peace and quiet
you want some you want quiet and quiet
there pieces is like a little louder
than quiet right
you want quiet and quiet
that's it
Wentworth Hotel can you see it
here we go there we go take a gander at
it
now I'll say this it's a little pricey
it's not crazy though
but it's a little pricey
um but I think it's the kind of place
where you're investing in what you get
on your return
I I felt fortunate that we could stay
there and I really really liked it uh
but it's quite I mean they don't even
um it's quiet
I just think of something think of
something real quiet Zach what is it
like a uh
like do you ever have a computer in your
room and you're like going to sleep at
night the computer's running yeah
like a little fan
like a fan in the computer you mean yeah
like a fan running in the computer or
like a
yeah that's that's not that quiet is
that quiet or not quiet you think
you want to go quieter than that
yeah yeah like what is as quiet as
something can be
what's the quietest you've ever been be
honest
when I was I went to my friend John's
house one time when I was a kid and he
wasn't there and his parents were
[__]
so I just uh
I listen for a little bit and then I
got out of there wow what made you get
out was it a certain did something was
there a certain did they shift gears or
something did something did was there a
part where you're like okay this is too
much because yeah that's real quiet when
you're trying to be so quiet that you
are
yeah if you're listening to somebody
else mate
or fight
if you're listening to like putting your
ear to the wall like your original
reality television was put in your ear
to the wall right before they had all
the shows it was Peep and Tom and or
putting your ear to the wall
and there'd be no you yeah you would
stop I remember literally I would
squeeze my ribs like this to keep my
heart from even making that sound that
it makes
so I could I didn't want to miss one
moment I didn't want that commercial
break of my heartbeat to interrupt the
just the pristine
pure reality television I was getting my
listening to my neighbor's fight or have
sex
or both
I remember one time people were
definitely
somebody kept punching somebody and then
you could hear him just
just
damn ejaculate
uh so what was it
uh what do you mean what were you saying
you said oh and so what caused you to
leave oh I just um
you know they were they were kind of
going out and
it was like my best friend yeah and
if I'm being being honest his mom was
hot and that was kind of a factor in it
too
but uh I mean you know how that like you
I felt like I couldn't it felt like
illegal to be there yeah
oh it's hard to it's there's definitely
um
it's hard to listen to somebody you care
about Mom
getting plugged up by somebody
thank you yeah I appreciate that man but
yeah there were oh I remember God the
neighbor woman if I got in the neighbor
woman's hamper I damn
I remember just
I would just stay in there dude
and just smell all her clothes and I
remember just wishing that she was my
mom
I remember that
what else we got the news hit us with
some of it Zach we got to get to some
calls a lot of calls have come into the
hotline 985-664-9503
there's some we saw
um Pentagon needed a new study and it
says 77 of Americans are too fat
mentally ill or on drugs to join the
military
welcome
well let me see about this 77 of Young
Americans go go to the information here
and what do they say in there
uh Pentagon study revealed that 77 of
Young Americans do not qualify for
military service without a waiver due to
being overweight so they're not good out
of the gate they would have to make an
exception right okay
um over the overweight what else
drug use drug and alcohol abuse is eight
percent
uh medical physical health seven percent
of it these are the percentage of people
who didn't get in and mostly though it's
overweight
okay
and that's between the ages of let's
give real information here please go
back down that's between the ages of 17
and 24.
okay
several key findings go on more please
several key findings were noted in the
summary report for example most
ineligible youth 44 are disqualified for
multiple reasons rather than in only one
area would you have any of these you
think uh
is that yeah I think I don't think I'd
make the way cut what is there a weight
cut do you know it
I don't know what the number is but I I
don't think I don't think I'm there dog
and that's okay man and any of the other
ones because it says with one you could
probably get a waiver
well I could get a waiver for the
overweight and then I can lie about the
mental like if there are any you can
just kind of lie about all that stuff
that's true huh yeah the weight you
can't lie about it you know so if you
can just get a waiver for that then
what's the problem
yeah yeah it's weird you can't really
dress in Black enough to look like
you're not on Lexapro or so
you know yeah
um
but okay so the way we keep you out and
you would be able to lie about the
yeah I lie about the other stuff then
we're good
yeah and that's our military and I could
get in shape I feel like it's you know
like couldn't they get us in shape
maybe so
so that's the news the largest increase
and I'm not shocked go back up to the
top of it there Bob
um
Americans are too fat I mean definitely
there are some places you can there's
people that you can see people and they
are bigger
than when they got here
uh and even if you'd have took them as a
baby and put them did like age
progression they would have never got to
where they are now there's people that
are bigger
and so that's
this also shows where we are in time I
think I think if
we it's been a while since we either you
really felt like a calling as a regular
person look there's no draft
there's no anything that has to you have
to stay on your toes
there's no mandatory service
so
yeah people I think you're going to get
fat you're going to get mentally ill a
lot of that goes in hand in hand too I
don't want to say that but
you know your brain is part of your body
if somebody cracked your body open your
brain's going to be in it and so
if you got gristle on your body you
could have gristle on your brain
it might show up differently that's why
sometimes I feel like if there were a
wharf there were a big like something
that would call everybody together and
bring everybody like okay we're on the
same team you almost wonder
if the dark artists that are out there
that are stirring the cauldrons you know
that are putting the ingredients into
all of this if that's what they're
aiming for what else we got Zach
um NASA announced the first crew that's
going to go to the moon for the first
um first crew in 50 years I should say
that's going to go to the moon this is
them okay we got a brother in there
definitely Lamar Odom they're sending
and three whites okay they're just gonna
fly around the moon and come back so
they're not going to land on that FYI
oh this sounds like uh
John Glenn he did the orbit no this
sounds like um
Bangbus is going to space or something
but yeah okay great another people are
going around the Moon Jesus Christ all
right one of these guys is Canadian too
okay well he's Canadian see yeah
but what are we doing what who can't you
know what I'm saying I feel like we've
been around the moon what are we are we
just trying to like and is this NASA it
feels like kind of like a soft way for
NASA to kind of strike back against some
of these more private firms that are
going out there
um
you know they're sending a brother out
there I respect that you know Brothers
in space uh how that's not a movie I
can't even imagine you know like I've
seen you do you know what I'm saying you
put six brothers either in space or at a
Bruce Springsteen concert
and that's that's solid gold that's you
know but yeah Brothers in space has got
to be
I mean that would win movie of the year
what else we got
uh Louisiana water plant employee
arrested after uh peeing in the drinking
water supply tank
twice oh yeah yeah they give you one
time or they warn you I remember one
time when I was over there something
that I had fell in there I don't want to
say it was like a might have been my
pager or something at the time we had
pagers you know yeah and I think mine
fell off into the thing and they
they weren't pleased but yeah
this is what you get when you let people
work at the power plant what is it at
the water plant
you know I did not I worked it 90 days I
did community service working there
City officials say they do not know a 57
year old Michael Mastin had urinated in
the water supply other times in the past
because the security archive only saves
footage from the last 30 days wow
well I can tell you to zoom in on the
guy right there
yeah he has brother
that dude definitely
this guy's just serving clear body piss
right here
Mastin was allegedly seen in security
footage leaving his office turning the
angle of the security camera then
urinating into the water supply wow
so he knows so he knows the camera's
there yeah he just can't help himself
wow bro that's what it's come to that's
what it's come to if you got that low
rise baby you got that one story
and you want that two-story baby you
want that crank up
I'm talking about that wiener topping
out Max weiner then blue chews licensed
medical providers will work with you to
find the right ingredient and strength
for your prescription
that's right Bluetooth is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as Viagra and Cialis
but in chewable form
and at a fraction of the cost
Bluetooth sildenafil and title Apple
tablets are chewable that's it they're
made in the USA Baby those are those
American rippers right there and they
help you get statuesque in there with
your body
and Witcher Wayne are topping up they'll
do it
and guys here's a special for you try
Bluetooth free
when you use promo code Theo at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
b-l-u-e-c-h-e-w.com promo code t-h-e-o
to receive your first month free when it
comes to saving money as a small
business
every little bit helps
you know that if you're running a small
business and you've got to get items out
man it's so in the beginning you start
printing a few labels and you put them
on and then but then next thing you know
you spent half your afternoon and you've
only put it out to about four or five
orders
which is fine
but as that grows you may need more help
ship station
hooks you up
ship station gives you access to
discounts of up to 84 off USPS and UPS
rates and you can manage every order
from one simple to use dashboard
when you lower your shipping costs and
make returns easy your customers stay
happy while you save money
ship station effortlessly integrates
everywhere you sell online including
eBay Shopify Etsy Amazon and more go to
shipstation.com and use code Theo today
and sign up for your free 60-day trial
that's right that's
shipstation.com code Theo
today and sign up for your free 60-day
trial you know you want your hair to do
good
you want that crop to rock out you want
you want dang Crows Landing in your hair
and you want them eating berries out of
it
that's the kind of Health you want to
have up top on your head and keeps
can help you
keeps
keep your hair they have more five star
reviews than any of its competitors
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss by the time they
are 35 that's right
keeps his expert recommended hair loss
treatments they have personalized
treatment plans that are recommended by
a licensed medical provider and
delivered straight to your door that's
right straight to the door bam get them
oh hair
that's how it goes they have 24 7 care
and support and low cost
if you're ready to take action and
prevent hair loss go to keps.com
t-h-e-o to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's
k-e-e-p-s.com slash Theo to get your
first month free
keeps.com slash Theo what else we got
I guess a couple migrants were arrested
because they killed a bald eagle and
they were planning on eating it and they
didn't know that you're not supposed to
eat the bald eagles
well wait are these illegal migrants or
illegal migrants as we have to wonder
because if you don't one of the things
that should be on the test is can you
eat bald eagle
yeah I guess there were two Honduras
Nationals who decided for unlawful
possession of of the eagle yeah
so just owning it or just possessing it
yeah
so I don't know I mean I think look it's
one eagle
well they're a protected species
who are the illegal aliens
uh both but the eagle
it's crazy I wonder what gets more
protection these days isn't that crazy
the guy said he's dead yeah
so
um interesting uh the Eagles did yeah
they ate it I mean look I've had rare
animal in my day
I bet things that I'm I've I've had
things I wouldn't even mention others
but it is what it is man
and uh I say let them have one
let them have one everybody deserves to
taste a little bit of ego I think
all right is that all we got
yeah I think so all right and that's
Zach from Cincinnati
ah I wanted to take my glasses offer to
kind of
just out of respect to to think about
this next part
um
you know they had a shooting here in
Nashville last week and um
and it was you know I'd never been in
something like that I'd never been that
close to something like that
I'd never been
I saw a cup I saw a couple Brothers
shoot each other one of them shot each
other in the back one time
outside of like I want to say like a
Dairy Queen Maybe
something like that one of those kind of
shooty urban kind of restaurants
but I'd never
seen something like I've never been
around something like this when this had
happened you know
I'd never been around something like in
the environment and you're you're in
traffic and people can't get you know
you can't get somewhere but you know
it's because all the parents in traffic
are trying to locate their children
and it's just I mean it's
you almost wanna
you wanna get in the way because you
want to try and do something but you
can't there's nothing you can do
it's just such an Abrupt insane finality
when that happens
uh
and I think I I just you know my heart
goes out to obviously all those people I
think you know I keep those people in my
prayers and
um
and you know and they say that prayers
don't help but prayers are for Pete
prayers are for Comfort it's just taking
a moment outside of yourself to to think
of some comfort for someone
it's just um
it's saying hey here this moment in my
life that feels peaceful I want to give
it to you
because you need it more than I do right
now
that's what a prayer is to me
I don't think I'm not sitting there
praying no guns or praying like don't
people shouldn't shoot like I don't know
everybody looks at it differently I'm
not trying to get into that discussion
so
I think what I was thinking of is just
how do we get how do you end up with
people that do this type of thing how do
you end up with these you know
childhood Shooters how do you end up
with people that go into a school
and do this and I think a lot of it is
to me a lot of it is a societal thing
and I'm not gonna everybody has their
views I'm not challenging your view here
this is just a space where I'm sharing
what I think and I could be wrong
that's totally okay
but I I feel and I think sometimes that
people don't have purpose
you have a country where
you know it used to feel like like if
you worked at a I mean I'm gonna go off
on some different thoughts here so if
you worked at like a business then
you had a lot of middle class businesses
you had a small a lot of smaller
businesses and if you work there then if
the company did well you did well and so
you had a sense of purpose maybe through
your work you know you're going to move
up the ladder you were going to be
um you know a foreman and then a a a
manager and then maybe have some
percentage share and then you know
you're going to get to a place
and now it feels I think like we've
we've let a lot of our companies get to
these big conglomerates and
it's about the bottom line
a lot of companies are beholding to
their shareholders but not to their
share croppers if you will to the people
working within the company
um so then what I'm saying is as a
person you may not feel any people you I
feel like you people can get a sense of
purpose from their work
so if you don't have that sense of
purpose then
then you can be pretty aimless right and
then if you don't have love like if
somebody doesn't love you or you feel
unloved or you don't love somebody like
if you don't have a um family
or a husband or wife or children
then you may not feel like a lot of love
right and so having love gives you a
sense of purpose
so
and we have less families these days the
familial structure is really kind of
broken down in America
you know you have a lot of single parent
homes you have a lot of two parents
having to work
um
so right there we're kind of
right there there's a place where people
where I feel like people used to get a
lot of purpose
and now
a lot of there's people that aren't
getting purpose from their work and
there's people that aren't getting
purpose from
uh their heart being fulfilled
by someone else or them being the piece
that fills someone else's heart
so right there man you have a lot you
have people who don't have a lot of
purpose
um
and then there used to be a sense of
America we are this country we are these
people we are united we are
we care about our neighbor
um
but that's a lot of that is going by the
wayside uh
we've become a
you know I feel like our our
political leaders have sold us out to
the highest bidder I feel like
it feels like
um
it doesn't feel any more like your
politicians or your leaders have your
best interest it doesn't feel that way
uh
and I'm not crying here I'm just trying
to I'm trying to see how do we get to
somebody that does something like that
that's what I've been thinking about
like how do you get there how do you get
to somebody that does an um shooting of
a school
you know
um
because you got to get there somehow
and it keeps happening
so anyway I think that a lot of it is
purpose if you don't have a purpose then
you are at the whim of whatever could
come along
you're at the whim of whatever influence
you whatever influence you get or
whatever ideology comes along they
um
that you can attach onto
and
so no job no love no real sense of Honor
or connection to your country
so then you I mean you're
and then on top of that if you if you
find that you're the victim if you start
to say well I'm a victim
you know it's my you know everybody else
I don't have any responsibility for
myself it's all your fault it's all your
fault
then you're gonna find not only are you
gonna find any ideology that comes along
which the internet is going to give the
internet it creates an algorithm that
gives you whatever you keep looking at
you get more of
so if you look at pudding or something
you get all pudding boy
and then three years from now wondering
why you too did you can't be in the
military now because buddy you putting
doubt you chose pudding and pudding
chose you
because whatever Vice it is it'll choose
you back so you so if you if you want to
be someone who
um is
you know you want to get involved with
us like a alt-right or alt left or you
want to get involved with
um
School shooters or uh anti-christian or
anti-um
I'm just trying to think something some
severe ideology you want to get then the
internet the Twitter whatever is going
to keep serving you it
so now you next thing you know you're
down a rabbit hole
and I think at that point
that's how you end up there I think
you end up in a place where I'm gonna
I'm gonna be seen I'm going to make sure
they know who I am
I'm gonna make sure that they say my
name or they hear my name or they see me
um
and that's just it's a that's
heartbreaking along the whole way
you know so I don't know I think I've
just been having a lot of thoughts about
that how do people end up there
how do people get to a place where they
would do that sort of thing now some
people I think are just crazy
and those are
um
crazy people that's different
but how does someone who's just been you
know
because next thing you know you're on
Twitter you get an anti-religious thing
you're like oh I went to a religious
school I also have trouble identifying
in the world maybe sexually so
man I'm a vict it's all
man you really
and then your Twitter your feed your
social media just keeps serving you more
of that hey you're right you're right
you're right
and then man you're gassed up
um
so I think a lot of it is a sense of
purpose you know
[Music]
and having a sense of purpose
and some of those sense of purposes like
the American when I can feel I felt like
when I was a child it felt like oh we're
part of this you know
but
it doesn't feel like that a lot anymore
but also I got to recognize that I can
still do things to try and make myself
have a purpose
you know uh
and you find purpose and you know I'm
fortunate that people love me my family
you know
um
you know that I have a job I have this
podcast to come to I have uh I have some
sense of purpose for myself
you know
and a lot of you guys do too I think
we're kind of a purpose-filled group or
we're trying to find that but I think
that's something that um
I feel like that's for me that's
something I think that that that's part
of that
is that man when you don't have a
purpose
the dark arts well they were they are
they are at your door they are waiting
on the edge of your ear to come in and
get your brain
and those include like you know all the
just the links just the rabbit hole you
can go down and it'll make you hate
because man you find a rabbit hole
you can when you get halfway to the
bottom of that [__] there's a HOA
meeting of just hateful Owners
Association
halfway through some of these rabbit
holes and it's just
it's just dangerous so
anyway
let's hit some calls huh
hey Mr Vaughn
um So lately
I have been coming home from work and I
like just to sit but look outside inside
I like to grab a beer and I can sit in
silence like not do nothing but my
wonderful girlfriend whom I love very
much
oh man she talks she talks so much oh my
god dude
first of all this I didn't believe you
had a girlfriend
I wouldn't I was not expecting that part
that seemed like a uh
a surprise to all of us listeners I
would say that but that doesn't mean
anything
and what I'm trying to say is yeah if
there's somebody that talks too much
dude it's unreal
it's unreal
I have a an early girlfriend that called
me sometimes she talks I don't need she
talks uh
oh my God if I even think about her
calling dude
I just get angry
that's how I get
because I don't want to listen to her
I have people there's people I won't go
to spend time with anything they talk to
me their wife talks about us we're not
friends anymore
we're not friends anymore
you know you sometimes you got to put
your put your spouse on a word count I
don't care who they are you get four
thousand words this spring
do what you want with them
but when it's done honey it's done
and that's that
get get a little step thing for words
oh [__] Cindy gots about uh seven
prepositions left boys
that's all she's got and two nouns come
on over
it's gonna be a quiet time we about to
enjoy the game
um
but yeah I don't have a solution to it
you chose her you chose someone's you're
you're a lifelong listener they call it
and you're just a damn you know you a
damn word pervert boy
so you need to do something when she
starts talking
get that wiener out
[__] start drinking your own spit do
something
and it could go the other way too if you
have a chatty husband
dude I was somewhere the other day we
were in somewhere eating some meat and
some guy wouldn't shut up
it was uh you can't enjoy just
you gotta shut up at times and here I am
talking into the second hour of a show
so what do I know
um
but
let's see what else we got here
yo the uh I need some advice I'm down my
name's Zach I'm down here in the booty
Louisiana area gang baby that's it booty
baby I feel you right over there by the
airport by the big Bridges
right over there near LaPlace where your
boy Billy conforto used to live and die
and some weird [__] been going on uh
I've been having two best friends
uh forever and I think they uh they fell
in love with each other and turned gay
and uh
I just don't know how to uh how to
handle it they acting weird
well they're not acting weird brother
they're gaying
and they're being gay
and that's uh
that's that's
people are doing it people are doing it
you couldn't
I mean these days you throw a damn
frisbee it'll hit a gay dude
that's that's how popular it is it's the
new
you know it's like doing the fries and
the
free chocolate freezy thing that's
remember when that came out that same
type of deal
but it's men it's men doing it
yeah I don't know what you do I think
you'd be a supportive friend
get them a trip get them a little
vacation or something if you're down
there and
you know I don't know
I don't know what do you do I mean are
you trying to see if they are in love or
are you
foreign
love
ends up trumping everything
and even if it's gay love
gay love still ends in
love
so
now I don't know I mean
yeah I don't know what you do I think
you [__] dap them up
but that's what's going on now every
people are being gay buddy and you gotta
if you
I can't but the odds you have two best
friends and they fall in love with each
other man
and party is probably jealous a little
that's what's the craziest part
because I remember if I had two other
friends growing up and if they even hung
out together without me
bro this [__] made me mad dude
it's like oh you're gonna tell me
[__] Terry
and [__] Gerald
we're at the skating rink yesterday
and I'm at my house
jumping through uh the ditch smoke
because people was burning trash in the
ditch by myself
playing BLM out there in the smoke
and they're having a fun time
it's tough
but do you willing to do gay to get all
of the friendship
and that's where one of them said Hey
look
I'm about to secure the bag dude he's
talking about nuts son and that is gay
men
praise God man thank you for sharing it
I think yeah you just got to be cool
with them
just chill man let them do it
let them do it and love them
all right let's take another one
Theo my name is Jamie I live in San
Diego
oh well dang
let's hear it Jamie onward the president
okay
that's oh yeah I look I think I this is
one thing I Joe Biden is he's a old man
he has dementia it is not cool to do
this to an old man
that's what I feel like
I don't care what your political stance
is your human stance
you know my father was uh
70 when I was born my father was an old
man so I grew up
with a with with an old man and watching
them
and watching them
and understanding their presence and
their ability and their Mobility all of
it
and we all know that this man is not
suitable for what we have him doing
or what people are pretending to have
him do because at a certain point
there's no way this guy is making
choices or making decisions there's it's
impossible
it's impossible
he's he's looking at things he's
ordering you know the other day he
ordered an almond or something off the
top of a building he doesn't know he
doesn't understand what's going on
this dude's petting visible cats and
damn sniffing children dude
it's all just old people stuff he's not
well
so at a certain point we're the kind of
country that says not only this is what
we do with our old
we we we take advantage of them to the
point where we'll even we're even
willing to let them be a shill
which I don't know what that is it's
it's something
it's like a
like a false front or something if for
whatever else is going on
and I think that's pretty sick man
if you saw somebody doing this to an old
person
you would think it was [__] up
that's what you would think if somebody
was doing this to you if somebody was
showing up at your grandfather's every
afternoon and making them go in the
front yard and say a bunch of [__]
and then making him go back inside
you know when they treating them up with
ice cream or something they got you know
or whatever
child sniffs or whatever they got a
little bag of [__] you know
nine-year-olds you know Barrette
sniffing or whatever I don't know
but it would be you know good and well
it would be messed up
so I think it's I think it's fi I think
it's [__] up by the uh
by all of by all politicians but also
it's a Democratic party it's your
candidate you got to know this isn't
cool it's just not cool
is not cool to do to an old person
you know I don't know what you would
it's like it's like senior trafficking
that's what y'all doing y'all seeing
your traffic in that man
and I think it's messed up and it makes
it just reminds me and I think this
makes me angry because it reminds me of
uh
you know you would see people take
advantage of old people sometimes you
know I would see that with my dad
sometimes people would take advantage of
him because of his age or they would
manipulate and reuse them in ways that
he didn't see because he wasn't
able-minded enough to notice and that
[__] made me angry
and it's the same type of [__] that
these folks are doing on this more um
on this national International scale and
level
you know I don't know I'm sorry to let
that get me keyed up but
that's real to me man that's real stuff
someone shouldn't take advantage of a
senior citizen like that
they should it's not it's not it's it's
messed up
it's messed up and we're acting like
it's
Regal
like who the [__] are you kidding that
this is a Regal way to go about anything
I don't know
um
what else do we have Zach any other
calls you recommend sorry I'm
I might need an afternoon off
it's just been a lot man
you know you go around you have a
there's just it's just a lot baby boy
what else who's somebody that's having a
tough time with something
hey Theo uh my name is Connor I'm from
Sacramento California
what's up Connor Thank you for calling
man appreciate you I just want to uh
first thank you for all that you do uh
you know or no you realize how much uh
you do for a lot of people you know you
the way that you talk you know I relate
with you so much even though we have
such different backgrounds and
upbringings and all that but I really
appreciate what you do and uh you know
recently in my life uh I'm a new car
thank you brother I appreciate the uh
the nice words man it's very kind of you
onward
I'm a new college student you know
starting my first year
um so a lot is changing in my life you
know my parents are splitting up uh like
the past couple months
and uh I broke up with my girlfriend
recently and it's just in a such a short
amount of time my life has changed so
much
so I guess uh what I'm trying to say is
even when my life or just
you know your life in general changing
so much you know I find I find I find it
hard to motivate myself to get out of
this low sort of uh ebb that I'm in
so what I'm trying to say is uh when
your life is changing so much and it's
throwing so much at you so quickly like
how do you how do you stay motivated to
really
uh grow as a person you know
anyways I hope
thank you brother that's a I appreciate
the call and um it's funny that's kind
of how this episode started out
um
yeah I think for one you got to find
some moments of your own you have to you
have to take a step outside of things
um
you have to find time to do that
you know uh and that means you know I
gotta I gotta limit myself better on my
phone and what I'm in what I'm in taking
my attention
what I'm giving my attention to
you know people we don't even have
imaginations anymore
because we don't need it the second my
imagination used to start like this your
brain you would have a moment of Peace
you sit somewhere
uh
and then your brain would get bored
so your brain would start thinking of
something or imagining something or
creating something right
because imagination is just
where creativity does bad in practice
right that's it
and
and next thing you know you would be
imagining something and you would
Daydream or you would come up with a
neat idea are you come up with a dream
or a goal
um
or a realization
something that you needed to take care
of that you hadn't
um
but that all that all happened because
you had that you had that open space you
had that time you had imagination
imagination did that now the second we
get a little bit of free time we go to
something
we go to a phone we go to a tick tocks
you go to something you do a vaping
you do it looking at a
titty
you doing something
you do with something
because you can't handle that uncertain
that what what's next what's next
but all that used to be next was
imagination
and we don't have that anymore we've
replaced it with let's just watch
other
let's just watch
others or let's find something to take
up this moment
um
so I'm sorry I don't even know where I
trailed I trailed off there what was I
saying to this guy is that
well he was originally asking about
um staying motivated when life changes
so much so fast right okay so you got to
get that moment for yourself sometimes
you have to find it right uh
because yeah that imagination would give
you fun ideas it would make your life
fun interesting you'd be able to
conceptualize you'd be able to get a
scope of your own life
um
so that kind of helped sort things now
we're just always like in the uh
experiential mode so we're not doing
enough of the Sorting to give us a good
view of things
um
and when you don't have a view of things
that can lead to depression you're like
oh I don't know what I'm doing
yeah because I'm not giving myself time
to know what I'm doing I'm just doing
um so sometimes you need a little bit
more time to know what you're doing to
get a look at things if you're if things
are too hectic uh
but yeah I think to stay motivated I
think more than ever we're at a time
where you have to come to your own
rescue
you know the dark the the the the the
the dark arts of uh algorithms and
screens and attention seeking
advertisement
you're depressed don't you want these
[__] Cadbury eggs
that [__] is at an all-time high
and
you gotta you have to sometimes you have
to come to your own rescue and that's
the worst thing we want to hear
because I want somebody to blame for how
I'm how how I how I'm am how I'm feeling
I want somebody to blame
I don't want to buy I don't want to have
to put it on my
you know
I don't want to have to put the cleats
on me
I just want to look at the shoe marks on
me and blame them on and say oh you know
Deborah did that
Jonathan did them you know but I don't
want to have to get up and make my own
prints in the world
so
I think some of it can be that you know
parents do get divorced a lot of times
when you get out of high school they've
been waiting to get divorced
so as much as that can be tough on you I
think try and recognize what their lives
have been like maybe just hypothyson
uh but recognize that they might have
held on for an extra three years because
you were still in high school as a child
um
so I don't know there's a lot there but
even if you have awareness you're
calling and thinking about what do I do
you know how do I stay motivated what
was the last party asked about what do
you ask about Zach
you just um not being able to like
waking up not knowing the motivation
yeah it was you know parents got
divorced uh broke up with his girlfriend
in college yeah
yeah you got a lot going on
so I think recognize that and give
yourself a little bit of space yeah you
might not wake up with the best with the
with a sense of purpose every day but if
you do start to develop one for yourself
man
it's going to be helpful and you can
hear something that I've learned
recently from a fella buddy of mine
and this is my buddy Thomas I used to
own gray block Pizza
and they were over there 1811 Pico
Boulevard on the way to the beach gray
block get that hitter
they was the original sponsor of this
podcast and he told me the other day
um
he said hey man and they make the Blue
Cue bass now he sold to one company and
went from doing Pizza pies to doing uh
Ice plunges
and he's he's the fella that gave me
that beautiful ice Plunge at the house
that blue cube
um
but he said hey man you can each day
when I wake up I decided if the world is
for me or if it's against me
and that's
that's pretty powerful because right
there you're going to get a little bit
of sense of purpose
but having a good sense of purpose is so
key man
um
and I believe the world is for you
I believe that the world is for us
I really do I think that there's
Predators out there
you know
there's dirty lungs out there with them
trumpets
tying the trumpets to their mouths
but that'll mean that we can't fight
baby that's what I'm saying
and I think having a sense of purpose
is key man and is the world for me or
against me because if I say the world's
against me then that's how my day is
going to go this world is against me
but if I say man the world is for me the
world wants me to do well the world
wants me to do better
the world wants me to see someone and
smile at them
the world wants me to let someone go if
they do something wrong not real like
look not crave they do something they
get your [__] get their [__]
you know or go get your [__] back that's
what I mean
but
yeah the world is it's for me so anyway
I believe that the world is for you I
believe that and every day you might not
succeed in thinking that way but over
time you can I believe that you can so I
just pray that you have some sense of
purpose man I pray that I do too every
day I don't but some that you know but
more often than not I feel like I do and
um I'm grateful for that uh but if
you're struggling if you're going
through something man just don't feel
like you're alone
you know there's people thinking about
you there's people you can't even see or
feel in the distance
that uh
that care about you
so
let's get out here the way we came in
sorry this is a loan but I hadn't been
together to spend time with you guys in
a little while and uh
and this was important to me I'm gonna
take a week off at some point in the
coming weeks and
so I'm gonna start to figure that out
but uh you guys be good to your sales
baby let's go out the way we came in on
Eddie nine volts
little
black fly
long time ago
and I think I took that love a little
too far
[Applause]
you will see the cigarette bottles on
the wall
[Music]
and all the empty bottles in the hall
if the water gets to rough you know who
to call